i've seen the comment section you guys
have a lot of medical questions and i
pulled together and i'm gonna answer
some of the most juicy ones right now
huge thank you to shipstation for
sponsoring this video
daniel von diego is it dangerous to
sleep next to a wi-fi router do we have
evidence that it's dangerous no do i
recommend it no move it away find a
different place for it don't keep it
next to your brain and also keep your
cell phone away from your brain and keep
your cell phone out of arm's reach that
you don't reach for in the middle of the
night if you can't sleep because that's
the sure-fire way to disturb your sleep
what advice do you have for the partners
of people who work in medicine given the
long hours of workload it could be
difficult to stay connected it's very
difficult do you know how many
relationships end when someone goes to
medical school
tons but also do you know how many
relationships form because you realize
that
like sometimes attracts like
humans are magnets
is it okay to lick a pen medically i
wouldn't advise is it okay
ethically morally i mean i think it's
fine don't lick the part of the pen that
releases ink that's not edible the way
that i think about pens is the same way
that i think about our fingers our
fingers are disgusting they have a lot
of bacteria on them like if you touch
your phone you're essentially touching
other people's poop there's poop on
everything these days keyboards phones
water bottles it's all over the place
it's just floating around and because of
that it's probably on your pen too and
if you're gonna put your pen in your
mouth you're putting poop in your mouth
so is it okay to lick poop no then not
okay to lick your pen that's how i'm
stating my answer is drinking my own
blood bad for me i promise i don't do it
on purpose but it happens a lot it is a
problem drinking blood is a gi disturber
whatever it's not good for your gi
system in some people it can cause
tremendous constipation because what is
blood having it iron in others it can
cause inflammation and irritation of
your gi tract leading to diarrhea how do
we know this in those who have frequent
nosebleeds and then do this start
swallowing a lot of blood it can lead to
nausea vomiting and or constipation
diarrhea if it stays there long enough
is it bad to hold and poop you have an
anal sphincter for a reason it's so that
you don't just poop while you're sitting
there if you lose control of your poop
it's called fecal incontinence and that
can happen as a result of all sorts of
medical problems a common one that we
talk about or learn about in boards is
something called cora equina syndrome
the lower end of your spinal cord
actually starts getting compressed and
it creates such compression that you
develop incontinence or decrease
sensation in the saddle area of your
body but holding in your poop is a
normal thing for a human so just be
reasonable with it don't overdo it
because you can actually hold in your
poop so long that you start developing
nausea and vomiting because you're
actually creating a backup in the system
so don't do that is it bad to stay up
all night several nights a week it is
absolutely bad in fact i'm gonna go on
record and say the
uptick in neurological conditions like
alzheimer's dementia etc i believe is
happening due to the fact that we no
longer respect sleep we pride ourselves
on sleeping less and working more we
value hustle culture we stay up late
because of social media and anxiety and
mental health struggles and as a result
we're creating brain problems back to
the questions in just a second but first
i want to talk to you about ship station
look last year i dealt with so many
headaches shipping out my new merch so i
get the struggle of running your own
online business things don't have to be
that hard though because thanks to
shipstation shipping becomes the easiest
part of the job their order management
and software is designed to make the
lives of retailers of all sizes
hassle-free from the dashboard i can
easily import orders from amazon ebay
etsy even my own website and automate
just about every shipping task even from
my phone they work with international
and local shipping companies around the
world like fedex and ups and i even get
access to discounted rates that are
usually reserved for fortune 500
companies without the contracts or
commitments 98 of companies that use
shipstation for a year keep using it for
as long as they're in business and now
it's available in australia canada and
the uk ship more in less time just go to
shipstation.com dr mike to get a 60-day
free trial remember doctor is spelled
out that's two months free of no hassle
stress free shipping all right let's get
back to the questions why am i able to
play any vr game for countless hours
without getting sick but the moment i
start driving a car i get motion
sickness in a vr people get motion sick
because there's a disconnect from what
their vision is seeing versus what their
semicircular canals and their ears are
experiencing so that sort of disconnect
can create nausea in some people that
you can get used to in an automobile
because you're constantly starting and
stopping you're having the opposite
disconnect where your semicircular
canals are experiencing a lot of
activation a lot of stimulus but your
vision might be looking at a still
object so that's a different disconnect
from on opposite ends of the spectrum
and you can have worse motion sickness
on one end but not the other every time
i wake up much earlier than normal like
to catch a flight i get really bad
indigestion is this just coincidence or
something going on there's something
going on the central nervous system of
our bodies works on two different
systems one is the rest repair digest
nervous system that happens and gets
activated when we sleep when we chill
when we meditate and then the flight or
flight response system which is like
what happens if we see a threat when
we're sleeping we're in rest digest if
you don't get enough sleep you don't
repair you don't digest well so when you
wake up early your body has to go into
fight or flight mode it has to kick in
your adrenaline in order to keep you
awake and allow you to function normally
and also many people to combat waking up
early drink a ton of caffeine which
stimulates acid secretion from your
stomach which can create
gastroesophageal reflux which is like
traditional heartburn what's the
difference between an allergy and an
intolerance such an important question
here because so many people say they're
allergic to things when they're really
not and then it creates other problems
so many of my patients say that they
have a penicillin allergy when they
actually don't and as a result they lose
a set of antibiotics they're actually
quite effective and have a low risk of
side effects and allergy is a histamine
driven response where you actually get
itchiness hives and you start scratching
your skin there's eosinophils present
you could also have an allergic response
through anaphylaxis where your throat
starts closing up you have swelling
because histamines start allowing the
swelling of tissues by making blood
vessels more porous then you get
cytokines and all these inflammatory
cells come and it becomes a big problem
because it closes off your airway and
intolerance is when something just
doesn't sit right with you it causes
some other malfunction in your body for
example if you're lactose intolerant
it's not an allergy because you don't
get a rash you don't get anaphylaxis but
you do have diarrhea so it's an
intolerance but not an allergy why is my
pubic hair so curly okay max did not
expect that one pubic hair is a type of
hair called terminal hair it starts as
vellus hair on our bodies when we're
babies vellus hair is the type of peach
fuzz hair that we actually still have on
our bodies and in certain areas due to
puberty we start developing terminal
hair it changes and it becomes deeper it
becomes more coarse becomes more curly
in fact pubic hair really doesn't grow
longer than like six inches because of
how often it sheds and breaks down also
really interesting about pubic hair
never thought i would say that but i
think the reason that it's curly is
because back in the day cavemen days
cave women days we had a bush and that
bush helped us have
better
locking in of our pheromones that smell
it was actually an aphrodisiac at this
time when we all walked around without
clothing it was at an advantage for
those who had curlier pubes to survive
also pubes are great protection from
friction what are smelling salts made of
how do they work you sniff them and the
nasal receptors get so irritated by them
it sends a shock response to your brain
and it wakes you up is there a way to
minimize the appearance of scars there
are things you can do about scars mostly
and where i see the best results from
through lasers and through surgical
approaches there's very little thing you
can do topically in terms of like
putting a cream on it there are some
creams that do some benefit in terms of
smoothing the scar but removing the scar
can only really be done surgically or
with a laser which is basically a type
of surgery in my opinion my friend dr
bonita does a great job of this on his
instagram channel dark highness 6666 i'm
a woman and i sneeze too loud it's
embarrassing what can i do to not sneeze
so loudly sneeze loudly just dab when
you do it don't let anyone judge you the
fact that you're
worried about this is worth
investigating with your doctor because
you should not feel ashamed by carrying
out a normal human body act in front of
others everyone sneezes and it's okay to
sneeze and if he sneezes loudly who
cares are there parts of my body i
shouldn't shave that's actually a good
question because you know we shave our
faces uh some people shave their armpits
benign but actually can create friction
especially if you do a lot of running
the problem with shaving your pube i
feel like we're covering a lot of pubic
stuff in this video the problem with
shaving your pubic region is there has
been some research showing that there
are increased sti rates when you do
shave because more skin on skin contact
so more chance to spread uh stis also
when you shave you can create micro
tears leading to openings in the skin
which can allow body fluids and blood to
get into thereby creating another
infection maybe skipping out shaving the
pubes
is not a bad idea when you need a knee
or hip replacement how do doctors know
the right size that's a good question
for an orthopedic surgeon i'm pretty
sure there's a measurement they do
prior to
inserting the instrument a look at the
x-ray and they'll get a general sense
but then they probably trial different
sizes like in the operating room and
they see orthopedic surgeons please
chime in hey doc what do surgeons do
with tumors once they've been removed
generally we send them to pathology for
analysis through microscopy to see a
what kind of tumor they are how
differentiated they are what cells are
present in some cases like with uh skin
cancers we do a cut out and sometimes we
look right then and there to make sure
that we cut out the entire margin of the
tumor to make sure that we didn't leave
any cancer cells behind why do humans
randomly get itchy i understand why you
itch from hairs or bugs being on you but
so often i itch when there's nothing
touching me what gives okay theresa this
is very important because if you're
itchy like that to that degree perhaps
there's a medical condition going on
perhaps allergic perhaps otherwise but
we would need to investigate that
further there's many reasons why humans
get itchy itchiness can come from
something physically bothering your skin
or a chemical reaction bothering your
skin both can cause itchiness and
there's also like the nerve thing like
nerves misfire and can make it feel like
an itching sensation is present when
it's not really there i'm thinking about
becoming a nurse but i have a serious
fear of needles do you think it's worth
pursuing or should i look into something
else that is something that you can
overcome there are legitimate medical
treatments and therapies targeted at
those who have phobias of any kind
needles are one that you can definitely
overcome so if that's the sole thing
that's preventing you from having an
amazing long career that is much needed
do not let it stop you from having a
very productive rewarding job because of
a phobia that you can overcome
is it dangerous to hold in a sneeze
click here to find out and also don't
miss out on your 60-day free trial to
shipstation by visiting shipstation.com
dr mike as always stay happy and healthy
[Music]